for a game developer tools are the life
force of your development cycle it
starts all the way at the beginning with
the compiler that the programmers use
all the way to the art creation tools
for the artist and even notepad and text
editors for the designers basically it's
how we get things done and believe it or
not this has actually been going on for
about 30 years now so it really hurts my
heart when we hear a lot of web game
developers say that they have to go
start from scratch creating a brand new
html5 game development tool that's
simply not true so before you go out and
actually start throwing all of your
venture capitalist money at a new studio
that's trying to put together some html5
development tools go back and take a
look at the stuff that we've been using
for the past 30 years to make really
good 2d and 3d games you'll actually
find that html5 and JavaScript in
particular is very capable of reading in
data formats from all these tool systems
so go out and educate yourself before
you throw your money away you'll find
some good stuff out there